a number of children with HIV and AIDS
have been expelled from schools in
Indonesia after other pupils parents
expressed outrage that infected children
were attending classes we traveled to
Indonesia and spoke to some of the kids
who were kicked out
[Music]
parents strongly objected to the 14th
children's attendance because they are
HIV positive we try to persuade them but
following their protests we took the
children out of the school now we're
helping to find a new school for them
[Music]
we also talked to the head of an NGO
helping children with HIV in Indonesia
for almost a week these children have
been staying home and not going to
school they are very upset about it and
really want to play with other kids
again they keep asking me when they'll
be allowed to go back I think children
should be treated equally they should
all have the right to go to school
these children have faced so many
obstacles since entering school after
kindergarten it's become the norm but we
will stay strong I think there is no
need to hide the location of the next
school of these children if we are open
it will be easier to explain to the
public that their disease is in their
body and will not easily spread to
others
you